Speaker 1: I want to look at
a couple clips from a recent
episode of the Stephen Bannon program.
Stephen Bannon interviewed a guy almost
as ubiquitous as Cher or Madonna. A
guy we know of as Pillow. Of course,
I'm talking about Mypillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell. Mike Lindell makes it clear he is willing
to lose everything over the machines.
Speaker 3: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Listen to this. It
is surreal and beyond parody at this point.
Speaker 3: How does that make you feel since
you've had your business destroyed, your life
destroyed, your employees destroyed? You're not
in Walmart. You're not anywhere because
of your crusade about these machines or.
Well, Steve, it doesn't matter if I if
it takes me to lose everything, I want
to save our country. And how does that make?
Speaker 1: He was willing to lose everything.
He told me during our interview that he's
in about $30 million so far to this election
nonsense. Still no proof from him about any of
his claims. And by the way, one other funny note
about this interview is about Twitter. Mike
Lindell is angry that even though all sorts
of right wingers and spreaders of lies about the
election have been unbanned from Twitter since
Elon Musk purchased it. He hasn't. And he's angry.
Speaker 3: My my shout out to Elon Musk would be,
you know, if you're social should be a new
platform of of free speech. Yeah. But yet
you're going to carve out the guys that fox about
our election crimes and our election integrity.
I don't think it's about free speech, but
I think it's I think I would like to give a
shout out to Elon Musk right now. Hey, check out
the evidence I was behind because I was telling
the truth. And that's that's that's disgusting.
And know to be one of the few people that. Oh,
yeah. Hey, hey, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho. They
have not they have not reached out to you and
asked you for the evidence you had and ask.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Elon is going to personally
decide whether to unbanned pillow after looking
at his supposed evidence which he's never revealed
to anyone. Every time I interview pillow he
tells me he'll send me the evidence he never
does. He told me he would send me pillows.
He never did. One other funny note on this.
After Pillow airs his grievances about
not being on band ban and actually says,
I don't even want to be on Twitter because
it's funded by the Chinese Communist Party.
Speaker 3: I have no interest in me on Twitter. I
would never be on Twitter because it is financed
by the Chinese Communist Party and Elon Musk got
to come forward and prove to people that it's
not Tesla. The whole deal stinks to high heaven.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it all stinks to Steve Bannon.
Listen, I believe we're coming to the end
of the pillow arc. Thankfully, in many ways,
I still am unsure. Is pillow a grifter or is he a
victim of the grift? I can't tell. I used to ask,
is he does he believe the stuff he says or
doesn't he? I believe he believes the stuff
he says. That seems really clear to me at this
point. The next question is, is he one of those
perpetuating the scam or has he simply fallen
for it? I believe he believes it either way,
but I can't tell whether he is a primary node or
a reactive node. Let me know what you think and
we'll have all these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.